thinking about taking on investors or  taking a business loan i think you  shouldn't do either of those if it's  your first business instead i think you  should do this you need to start working  with what you've got and learn how to  hustle and make money because  realistically your first business is not  going to be your last business if you're  going to be an entrepreneur for the long  term ideally you want to take really  capital light businesses so service  businesses are examples of that where  you're really just trading time for  money but you're going to learn a lot of  these other skills and those tend to be  higher cash flow businesses that allow  you to save up the money and learn the  skills so that if you do have an  opportunity you want to go after you'll  have the capital and the mental  resources to be able to do it and win